clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic merci abonne toi
bonjour comment ça va vous bien pas ouf
ouais c'est compliqué et moi moi comment
ça va quoi de neuf
et justement c'est pour sa cure
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez remarqué comme 2020
ça a été une année un peu bizarre un peu
je sais parler habituel
non y'a que moi non mais non bien sûr
que non il n'y a pas que moi bon alors
davantage de cette année c'est que ça
nous a montré à quel point tout ce qu'on
a construit dans notre vie même si ça
paraît hyper solide et bah ça peut
expliquer au lendemain comme ça sans
prévenir si c'est un avantage autant
essayer d'en tirer quelque chose de
positif
alors c'est vrai que dit comme ça ça
peut faire flipper je reconnais mais en
même temps ça nous aide à relativiser
sur l'importance des choses et ça ne
monte que là il faut pas avoir peur de
changer parce que des fois les choses
elle change tout seul sans prévenir tout
autant changer pour des trucs qui nous
plaisent à nous bon bref on va reparler
de tout ça un petit peu plus tard mais
pour l'instant quand même le colis alors
j'aurais pu vous faire une vidéo par
semaine avec la polémique du jour la vie
de machin l'interview de trucs le
nouveau docu qui fait parler
bon j'aurais pu faire ça ça m'a pas
semblé très intéressant c'était déjà un
peu partout et puis plus ça va plus on
se rend compte que où on apprend les
choses au fur à mesure que toutes les
prédictions sont démenties voilà donc ça
me paraissait pas hyper légitime et
ibères pertinent de vous abreuver d'un
fond sur ce truc dont on est déjà
abreuvées mais quand même là maintenant
il me semble qu'il ya un truc
particulièrement intéressant et il me
semble qu'il ya un truc particulièrement
importants dont il va bien falloir qu'on
parle ensemble
voyez le truc non bah oui le vaccin le
vaccin parce qu'il va arriver très
bientôt ils vont arriver très bientôt
même parce qu'il y en a plusieurs
donc je vais vous préparé une vidéo là
dessus parce que franchement ça mérite
l'idée très concrètement je vois bien
que vous vous posez toutes et tous
pleins de questions
moi aussi évidemment c'est des questions
qui me semble dans la majorité des cas
légitime c'est normal de se demander ce
qu'on va se faire injecter un truc voilà
donc il ya plein de questions hyper
intéressante plein de questions super
légitime et je me propose moi de me
répondre
voilà plus faire le titre recherche
d'interroger des gens j'ai déjà pris pas
mal de contacts
et puis et puis de répondre à tout ça
donc ce que je vous propose vous envoyer
un petit mail à l'adresse question dtc @
gmail point com avec comme objet
question vaccin pour que je me retrouve
moi je checke tout ça je prends les
questions les plus fréquemment posées
loup les plus pertinentes
voilà je les rajoute à ma liste que j'ai
déjà chopé à droite à gauche
je fais tout ce que j'ai à faire je
retourne cette vidéo et je vous la
diffuse quand elle est prête c'est à
dire congé toutes les infos pour
répondre à toutes les questions que vous
posez
est ce que ça vous va donc question dtc
aruba gmail.com objets question vaccins
et c'est parti en attendant ici sur dtc
je vais vous postez des petites infos
utiles cool marrante insolites des fun
fact tout ça sur la sur la santé
évidemment ces déconvenues que j'ai déjà
commencé à mettre sur tik tok
vous connaissez la petite goutte celle
quatre ans à finir dans le slip
donc vous pouvez aller voir si ça vous
intéresse c'est vous chercher at jml sur
petit coq c'est comme sur instagram html
c'est comme sur twitter à djenane voilà
donc vous pouvez allez voir c'est si
vous voulez si vous voulez pas à bâle je
voulais mettre ici parce que je suis
quand même super sympa mais quand même
je vais pas tout mettre ici donc allez
jeter un petit coup d'oeil aussi sur tik
tok ne serait ce que parce que je suis
super sympa ça mérite donc des vidéos
avec des infos des fun fact et c'est sur
la santé parallèlement pas ici mais sur
twitch je me suis lancé j'ai lancé ma
chaîne vous pouvez aller voir aussi
passé me passer voir on sait qu'on
discute pour l'instant on est en train
de construire la chaîne et à ce à quoi
ça va ressembler tous ensemble donc à
passer c'est cool je vous dis on discute
on dit à quoi on a envie que ça
ressemble plus tard c'est arras et c'est
hyper sympa je souhaite évidemment tous
les liens vers tous les réseaux sociaux
et verte witch et c'est dans la
description de la vidéo et n'hésitez pas
à me suivre sur un style compagnie parce
que j'annonce les lives régulièrement
donc il ya ça qui va qui va continuer
sur le sur le mois de décembre
venez on se parle on se parle là bas
ensuite en 2021
tout ça ça va continuer les trucs
nouveaux mais aussi le dtc à l'ancienne
parce que c'est quand même chouette
c'est quand même pour ça que d'être là
il y aura des nouveautés aussi parce que
bon vous n'êtes pas là pour s'emmerder
1,2 mille ans on est bien chargé j'en
profite pour vous remercier vraiment
pour de vrai d'être là tous et toutes
depuis depuis un petit moment maintenant
on est plus de 700 milles c'est quand
même
c'est quand même pas rien ça fait ça
fait plaisir et puis c'est un truc qui
s'est construit au fur et à mesure merci
d'être là c'est chouette
et puis j'espère que vous allez bien
pour de vrai parce que déjà de base là
en ce moment c'est pas la saison la plus
longue de l'année mais là en plus avec
confinement re confinement couvre ce
leurs événements et s'immisce avec des
masques le nouvel an on sait pas trop
les bars qui sont parrains ouvert les
concerts on sait pas quand ça va
reprendre plus tous les problèmes perso
tous les problèmes pro qu'on a tous plus
ou moins cette année on est quelques-uns
et quelques-unes à ne pas être au top de
notre forme actuellement donc j'espère
que pour vous ça va à peu près et si
c'est pas le cas
entourez vous restez pas seul autant que
possible parler avec des gens parler
avec des proches des gens de confiance
des proches ou des mois proche
on a déjà parlé mais il faut on est
surpris par les ça soulage ça libère et
puis ça force à mettre des mots sur des
trucs
pas forcément en tête et puis sa salle
avantage d'avoir un regard extérieur sur
les choses dès fois il suit pas grand
chose pour débloquer une situation donc
restez pas seul parlé à des proches à
des professionnels à n'importe qui un
mois à mon petit niveau qu'est ce que je
peux faire je peux vous conseiller de
retourner voir de vidéos à moi une sur
le confinement où je venais quelques
conseils pour pas devenir dingue en vrai
ça s'applique à toutes les périodes
compliquées de la vie là c'était pour le
confinement mais tout ce que je dois en
reste vrai en ce moment et puis
peut-être celle sur les moyens de faire
passer une crise d'angoissé parce que
peut-être que vous avez ça en ce moment
c'est impossible il ya aussi un podcast
que j'ai fait avec la mutualité
française dans laquelle on discutait
avec des professionnels sur les
meilleurs moyens les meilleurs orienter
aider quelqu'un qui va pas bien parce
que nous on va peut-être pas bien et
autour de nous il ya des gens qui vont
pas bien
et en ce moment on a besoin de ce donc
donc voilà on vous va se retrouver comme
le veulent à l'expression consacrée très
vite pour des nouvelles vidéos blabla
machin etc
mais on a tendance à jamais été aussi
vrai je le dis tout le temps depuis 89
presque cinq ans maintenant mais ça là
en ce moment ça prend vraiment tout son
sens
prenez soin de vous prenez soin des
autres
on vient d'en parler mettez vous bien
mais pas forcément trop en tout cas
autant que possible et puis surtout
portez vous bien